ne pas céder à la panique c'est ce qu'a
déclaré la commission européenne lors
d'une conférence de presse
devant l'explosion de k2 coronavirus en
italie bruxelles a donc décidé de lancer
l' alerte tout en appelant au calme et à
l'unité de cette situation je voudrais
dire aujourd'hui que nous allons faire
tout notre possible pour aider les états
membres à faire face à la situation
bien sûr prendre cette situation très au
sérieux mais nous ne devons pas céder à
la panique et plus important encore à la
désinformation
nous devons être très sûrs aidant m
réponse cohérente et coordonnée avec le
développement du virus sur le continent
c'est aussi la question de la libre
circulation des personnes au sein de
l'espace schengen qui est posée pour
l'instant la commission n'entend pas
faire de recommandations sur la
fermeture éventuelle des frontières
sujets qui relèvent de la prérogative
des états membres nous pensons que les
mesures doivent être en premier lieu
fondée sur une évaluation crédible d
ascq et des preuves scientifiques
je démens les mesures doivent être
proportionnées et troisièmement elle
doit être prise en coordination avec
d'autres une coque nous devrions agir en
tant qu'union et non individuellement le
code des frontières schengen permet de
réintroduire temporairement les
contrôles aux frontières
une telle mesure comme je l'aï dit je
dois être prise compte tenu des
conditions que je viens de mentionner
l'italie est d'ailleurs proposé une
réunion des ministres de la santé des
pays frontaliers de la péninsule ce
mardi après midi pour déterminer des
lignes d'action commune et un contrôle
aux frontières pourraient être rétablis
il faut dire que l'inquiétude gagne les
villes proches de la frontière italienne
en france la préfecture des alpes
maritimes a annoncé ce lundi après midi
la mise en place d'une cellule de
vigilance quotidienne et le renforcement
du dispositif sanitaire des mesures de
précaution pour les personnes revenant
du nord de l'italie seront également
prises dans tout l'hexagone